foreign
next we have Bruce in Boston hey Bruce
welcome to the show
hi thanks for taking my call absolutely
how can we help
oh I'm in kind of a mess
um so my wife and I have been married
for 20 years back in 2010 we were
totally debt free right everything they
talk into the phone man
and uh right after that we bought two
brand new vehicles
and from that point uh forward we've
been disconnected not able to get on the
same page I'm doing a monthly budget
uh fast forward to now
um she got a new job about a year ago
and uh the new job has her uh using her
credit card our credit card to make
purchases for the company
company pays for those purchases but uh
I think that the company should be get
their own credit cards and they make
their own purchases not us yeah
I would agree with that so what's your
question
how do I get her to understand about the
companion being purchasing their own
materials
I think it's a bigger question yeah so
you can't come into at the tail end of
of
I mean you guys getting off kilter
buying two new cars back in 2010
that's not the reason you can't have a
budget there's something beneath the
thing that you're talking about
yep I would agree with that what is it
um I would say
um
part of his budget not not wanting to do
a budget nope no no that's not it what's
beneath that
why does she not want to
I think she's afraid of um money
commitment
she thinks she's not going to have any
money to spend even though we do have
plenty of money to spend why do you
think she feels that way
um
money controlling I'm not money
controlling I just like to do a budget I
don't spend a whole lot just on what's
needed
are you a safe person to Anchor to
most uh communicative yeah
and so you see how over 15 years
um or 12 Years A Dance emerges
where you're hard to talk to you're hard
to connect with so she has to create a
world that she can exist in
and in that world the only joy she's got
is buying crap
and the only safety she has is Financial
Security I've got the ability to get
whatever I need whenever I need it and
you
feel like the rug keeps getting pulled
out from under you and it's frustrating
and you don't know how or don't want to
say anything
and then this Just Dance starts and then
you end up further and further and
further apart and now she's in a
situation that I think is asinine it's
insane that a company is asking an
employee to put things on their on their
personal credit card that's just dumb
it's just dumb
um but y'all you you don't have the
tools you don't have the relational
Equity to have this conversation
I would agree and now it sounds like a
personal attack on her she's saying oh
you hate my job which is an identity
thing it's all you see what I'm saying
you having this and you're right you're
actually right the the I usually don't
like to say that in a marriage
conversation you're right and that's not
the point right now
right the point is she can't hear you
and you can't hear her are you all done
um well we've been
for the last 15 years and um I would say
we are not done because we still love
each other and we have worked on we've
gone to counselors a couple of times
and uh since code then they went to
remote and that didn't work for us and
for the last two years we have not seen
anybody why
um so we couldn't do the whole remote
thing of in-person work for us better we
haven't gotten back down anybody since
that's what I'm asking for a while
that's what I'm asking you is like if I
need antibiotics and there's a flood and
I can't get to
Walgreens to go get them the moment the
water recedes I'm going to be banging on
that door to go get my what I need to be
healthy and well
okay uh I'm gonna put you on the spot
John absolutely because you've done this
in another call at previous shows and I
was like I feel like that this could be
Bruce you've painted a picture before of
a husband going out to dinner with his
wife holding her hands looking across
the table
and just speaking to her and saying out
loud the truth of what they both know
and him admitting
you know baby I've not been I'm not an
easy person to talk to
here's the situation that I know I've
create and start saying out loud the
things that you guys know and I feel
like a wife hearing her husband take
responsibility and at least
acknowledging what's going on is a
really beautiful thing do you remember
doing it all the time well say it to him
because I'm like that's a great picture
because it gives like you always say
paint the picture this picture of a
husband and wife sitting across from
each other and they're actually being a
helpful conversation
but it starts with responsibility that's
right so um what Rachel's getting to is
is is this at the end of the day you
can't make your wife do anything
it's frustrating
she's gonna have to choose to either a
com see the light about how much more
peaceful her life can be with Financial
Security or
especially in the beginning choose to
meet her husband's needs because she
loves him more than she loves
um
feeling warm and fuzzy at night for a
season okay so all you can deal with is
your thoughts and your actions and so
this whole Healing Begins
with you going to dinner
or you taking her out to breakfast one
morning and haven't already written this
stuff out
and you hold her hand and you look
across the table at her and say not we
need to or you need to know I have
screwed this up for 15 years
and that's you being ownership being
husband yep that's extreme ownership
it's you taking a knee and saying all I
can own up to is what I've contributed
to this and then here's the important
part after you take ownership here's the
scary vulnerable part for you that
part's actually easy I screwed this up
I'm sorry here's the hard part you
saying here's what I really need
here's what I need
and you'll feel less than you'll feel
small you'll feel not like the Boston
man that you think you are but I'll tell
you the time when I my marriage was on
the Rocks brother and I sat down and one
of the things I told my wife is I said
I'm ashamed to even say this out loud
I'm a six foot two Texas male
but I need you to say you're proud of me
because I'm working as hard as I can for
one thing that's to make you proud
and I just want you to say that I'm
doing a good job
I just needed to hear that and it was
embarrassing to say and it was a moment
of catharsis for me to say it out loud
and my wife said man it would have been
awesome to know 15 years ago and now she
doesn't miss a beat and I wish I didn't
need that dude I wish I was so cool I
did I just wanted my wife to think
because I really try to impress her and
I wanted to be enough for her and so
it's you mining you going way down in
the depths and saying what do I need I
feel scared and terrified and unsafe
with how much money we owe I'm terrified
it would mean the world to me if you
help me feel more safe by doing a budget
with me
that's totally different than you need
to get your butt on the Ramsey plan you
see what I'm saying
yes that's totally me okay yeah yeah
don't do that because you know what I'm
not talking to you either man and I'm
gonna go it doesn't work yeah no it
doesn't work so this is a total this is
going to take some time for you to write
down your needs to be honest with
yourself here's what I need
because it starts out with I need more
more sex what I really need is more
undivided attention from you I need your
attention I miss you I need intimacy I
need us to just be like hang out all
right so it starts in these big
announcements I need to just get out of
debt I'm terrified at how fragile our
economic situation is in our home
you see there's a difference there man
and I want you to get to those needs and
write them down and take her out
um and have that conversation stay on
the line I'm going to send you the
questions for humans cards for couples
it'll give you all some things to talk
about as you're having these hard
conversations and it'll give you some
tools to practice having conversations
again that's great thanks Bruce thanks
for calling us
um hope all well for you you and your
wife